[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale du jour tout de suite
les titres de ce mardi 22 janvier la
neige de retour dans les yvelines il en
est tombé jusqu'à 5 cm aujourd'hui le
territoire et placier toujours ce soir
en vigilance orange alors qu'un nouvel
épisode est attendu à partir de 21h dans
cette édition nous verrons comment saint
quentin en yvelines et le département
gère la situation les chefs de maisons
de retraite yvelinois s'affrontent un
concours de gastronomie est organisée en
ce moment par silver fourchette
programme de sensibilisation à
l'alimentation des seniors hier la
première épreuve se déroulait à
guyancourt nous avons suivi l'une des
équipes concurrentes
enfin la finale est programmée ce samedi
le mémorial de caen accueille le
concours des plaidoiries des élèves
avocats parmi les onze personnes en lice
une étudiante de versailles laura
giovannoni est notre invité les yvelines
ont donc connu aujourd'hui un épisode
neigeux avec plusieurs centimètres
tombés météo france qui place toujours
ce soir le département en alerte orange
pour la neige et le verglas leers qui
court jusqu'à demain 6h comment comment
la situation est elle gérée à saint
quentin en yvelines et quelle réaction
pour ses habitants éléments de réponse
avec patrick jacques de dixmude et
mickaël landreau
la neige a fait son grand retour ce
mardi 22 janvier dans les yvelines entre
1 et 5 cm sont tombées dans la matinée
sur le département
c'est une saison à c'est bah ouais faut
pas que ça continue trop mais bon bah
c'est comme ça quoi bon marché oui pour
marcher sur alger normes et jade un jeu
ça du hautbois à moi d'autres au
contraire n'était pas aussi
enthousiastes à c'est très très
compliqué c'est très dur fin on n'arrive
pas à avancer fin du coup c'est un peu
le bordel falé fois les feuilles très
doucement faut faire attention au choix
il ya cessé ça glisse beaucoup faut
faire attention aux freins faut pas
freiner fort faut freiner tout doucement
des recommandations qui s'appliquaient
également aux voitures certains
automobilistes illinois n'ont pas pu
éviter les dérapages dans les virages le
trafic était notamment difficile sur les
petits axes routiers
ça glisse beaucoup je viens juste de
versailles là et à 10 alors ça va ça va
carrure pour rendre la circulation la
plus praticable possible sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
12 déneigeuses ont réalisé chacune entre
30 et 40 km d'intervention sur les
routes
les opérations ont débuté à partir de 11
heures après une première sortie de
prévention dans la nuit c'est un jour
exceptionnel puisqu'en s'attendait pas à
autant de neige ça soit requis et nous
il faut qu'on puisse déneiger pendante
les véhicules ne soient pas là donc
c'est pour ça forcément en détermine des
fois des tranches horaires qui sont
peut-être pas comprise par la population
mais en fait on prend des tranches
horaires c'est tout simplement pour
pouvoir déneiger pendant qu'ils aient
moins de circulation et les déneigeuses
devrait de nouveau sortir dans les
prochaines heures de nouvelles chutes de
neige sont attendues dans la nuit
et après saint quentin en yvelines
voyons comment s'est déroulée la journée
sur les routes du département bonsoir
pierre les blés vi
avec nous par téléphone vous êtes
adjoint à l'unité programmation
entretien des voies pour les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine et de département a
écrit gère en commun pendant l'hiver nil
650 km de voies 159 agents sont
mobilisés dites nous comment s'est
déroulée la journée pour votre service
et ce qu'il y ait beaucoup de sorties et
qui se sont déroulés très tôt ce matin
alors effectivement on a mobilisé toutes
les équipes qui étaient mobilisables dès
la nuit dernière on avait 46 agents
d'astreinte qui était programmé pour
intervenir à partir de minuit 1h
l'événement est arrivé un peu plus tard
dans la matinée
ils sont intervenus à titre préventif
jusqu'à 8 heures du matin puis en titre
curatif avec du raclage et du salage
tout au cours de la journée avec une
bascule des équipes de jour qui ont
continué le traitement surtout toute la
journée jusqu'à 17 heures ce soir pour
faire un cas il ya quelques camions qui
prêtent encore des zones circuler où il
ya des résidus de neige
vous évoquez les opérations de salage
qu'on connaît très bien et ce qu'il ya
d'autres types d'opérations des
opérations aussi préventive autre que le
salage pour pour traiter ces voies alors
c'est principalement du salage après on
épand de la bouillie de sel c'est un
mélange de saumur et de c'est une
composition saturé en fait qui a qui
tient un petit peu mais à la chaussée
qui est plus efficace en préventif que
des grains de sel qui peuvent être
chassés de la chaussée et qui ont leurs
actions uniquement par l'apport de la
neige mais le le deuxième type de
traitement c'est un traitement de
raclage avec des raveaux des lames en
caoutchouc qu'on peut sur la chaussée
comme on peut voir régulièrement dès
qu'on a au delà de 3 cm 2 de cumul c'est
très sceptique on vient de faire parce
que ça dégage la chaussée circuler une
dernière question météo france place
toujours ce soir le département des
yvelines ainsi que celui des
hauts-de-seine en vigilance orange neige
verglas
les prévisions parle d'ailleurs d'un
deuxième épisode neigeux qui
interviendrait ce soir ce avec le même
type de mobilisation ce soir pour les
agents alors en nombre fait le même type
de mobilisation on a toutes nos équipes
d'astreinte qui était en repos en
deuxième partie de journée et qui
reviendront selon les cas entre 22h et
minuit sur pour intervenir voir un peu
plus tôt si le phénomène neigeux est un
peu plus intense
on nous annonce pour l'année prochaine
des chutes et parque de neige qui seront
avec des cumuls moins important mais
cumulées est associée à un risque de
températures proches de zéro donc de
congélation de certaines zones humides
donc on redéploie toutes nos équipes
d'astreinte sur les différents secteurs
pour intervenir à titre préventif et
éventuellement un clip curatif si
l'événement est un peu plus intense
merci pierre yves lévy d'avoir été avec
nous par téléphone je rappelle que vous
êtes adjoint à l'unité programmation
entretien des voies pour les yvelines et
les hauts-de-seine
merci d'avoir été avec nous la neige qui
a donc cessé de tomber cet après midi
vous l'entendiez un deuxième épisode et
s'est cependant pas drôle pardon prévue
aux alentours de 21h ce mardi soir des
chutes de moindre importance est plus
localisée
météo france maintient son alerte orange
neige et verglas jusqu'à demain matin à
6 heures et conséquence des intempéries
et de nombreuses perturbations sur les
routes et transports la circulation est
ralentie sur l'a13 et la n12 la vitesse
y est limitée à 80 km/heure la n118 où
plus de 900 personnes étaient restées
bloquées est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nouvel ordre la gendarmerie
yvelines a d'ailleurs recensé une
vingtaine d'accidents dans sa zone de
compétence à saint quentin en yvelines
le trafic des skis vu çà a été retardé
l'élu ce particulier non pas à circuler
une grande partie de la journée
autre conséquence de la neige le plan
grand froid a été activé à part il
permet l'ouverture de places
d'hébergement d'urgence supplémentaires
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur cet
épisode neigeux dans le reste de
l'actualité le concours de gastronomie
silver fourchette s'y affrontent des
chefs cuisiniers professionnels des pas
d'une épreuve se déroulait aujourd'hui à
son chant hier le concours
investissaient les locaux du cfa
trajectoire de guyancourt marie l'ania
piccino et et macabre ibarra ont suivi
l'une des équipes en compétition ce
matin-là en cuisine le chef amadou
diallo donne ses indications assez connu
et ça ça va continuer notre garniture
pour le poulet s'est commis il vient de
les rencontrer tous trois participé au
concours silver fourchette pour cette
épreuve de qualification cinq équipes
constituées d'un chef cuisinier d'ehpad
l'involontaire gastronomes et d'un élève
du lycée hôtelier ou trois heures pour
sortir un plat et un dessert
les équipes ont été tirés au sort vous
connaissez personnel de venir vous
montrer une autre image là
de la cuisine dans les étages au menu de
notre équipe numéro 4 escalopes de
poulet farci et sa pomme de terre
surprise pour le plat je dois mettre les
petits pois dans ce saladier pour
pouvoir après les mixer pour pouvoir les
mettre dans la pomme de terre surprise
et rose feuilleté aux pommes et sous
caramel laitier en dessert c'est la
mission des milices des prêts non
professionnel de cuisine mais
volontaires pour représenter son
établissement mais résidents vont venir
cet après-midi représenté aussi
l'établissement ils ont créé leurs
banderoles l'après-midi les neuf
établissements représentés ont fait le
déplacement pour venir encourager leurs
chefs ou volontaire gastronomie après
dégustation le jury rend son verdict
amadou diallo et son équipe sont arrivés
deuxièmes ils sont qualifiés pour la
finale du 11 février
très bonne expérience en plus on fait
profiter nos résidents et puis ça donne
une image de nos établissements qui est
voilà qui est assez forte quand même
auprès de personnes âgées et qui la
gastronomie les aussi de ce concours
c'est de d'ouvrir en fait des ehpad sur
sur le territoire de montagne sont des
lieux de vie qui qui s'engage pour le
bien manger pour bien vieillir
cette édition du concours silver
fourchette est une première dans le
département des yvelines
quatorze établissements étaient inscrits
ils sont huit restaurants du département
à avoir cette distinction et ils la
gardent le guide michelin 2010 9 révélé
hier n'a retiré aucune des étoiles aux
établissements yvelinois le gordon
ramsey l'angélique et la table du 11 à
versailles le numéro trois au tremblay
sur mauldre la table des blu à dampierre
en yvelines le village à marly-le-roi et
la corniche à rolle bois ce qui a fait
son entrée au guide l'an passé
conservent leur étoile pas d'entrer au
palmarès à noter cette année en plateau
avec moi mon invité laurent giovannoni
bonsoir vous êtes élève allées d'accès
la haute école des avocats de la cour
d'appel de versailles qui est située à
viroflay
et je vous reçois parce que vous êtes en
finale du concours des plaidoiries des
élèves avocats il se déroule ce samedi
ça sera au mémorial de caen vous y
présentera une plaidoirie on va
présenter le sujet dans un instant déjà
que représente ce concours pour vous
pourquoi y avoir participé alors chaque
école d'avocat de france envoie un
candidat pour la représenter donc
j'aurai l'honneur de représenter les dac
l'école d'avocats où je fais mes études
et puis le concours des avocats est très
connue au mémorial de caen il se
déroulera le lendemain
cette année donc c'est ça sera un gros
week-end autour de la plaidoirie qui se
déroulera à caen c'est exact comment
s'est déroulé le concours
quels étaient les étapes précédentes à
ce concours alors il ya une première
étape de sélection écrite donc chaque
candidat envoyait une ébauche de la
plaidoirie et du sujet qu'il aimerait
proposer puis la demi-finale qui a
consisté en cinq minutes de plaidoirie
devant le jury de l'école de les dagues
donc voilà puis la sélection s'est faite
le jour même
et qu'est ce que ça peut vous apporter
vous êtes dans les tous derniers mois
les toutes dernières semaines de vos
études qu'est ce que ça peut vous
apporter de participer à un tel concours
mais déjà forcément de de m'exercer à à
la plaidoirie et puis de représenter mon
école certainement de rencontrer des
professionnels sur place
donc voilà j'espère surtout profité aux
temps du temps de parole qui me sera
accordée que j'ai pu en profiter durant
la sélection pour la demi finale et donc
on sera on a quelques jours là tout
juste de cette finale quel est votre
état d'esprit est ce qu'il ya du stress
vous êtes pressé d'être à cette finale
alors forcément un petit peu un petit
peu de ce 13 après justement on est on
est dans la dernière ligne droite donc
là j'ai très envie d'y aller et puis
comme je vous le disais devoir profiter
du temps de parole qui met qui m'a
accordée alors cette plaidoirie vous la
présentez sur dix minutes on va
présenter d'ailleurs comment va se
dérouler cette finale dans un instant
et vous avez choisi comme thème vous
avez vous parlé de l'histoire d'une dame
theodora vazquez une salvail
salvadorienne qui est elle déjà
présentes on l'a qui est-elle theodora
vazquez c'est une femme de
trois ans en 2007 quand les faits se
sont déroulés elle était enceinte de
neuf mois de son deuxième enfant
et puis à neuf mois de grossesse elle a
accouché d'un enfant mort né suite à une
agression qui s'est déroulé une semaine
auparavant et donc le contexte un petit
peu du salvador un article du code pénal
salvadorien pénalise l'avortement en
toutes circonstances or dans les faits
les juges requalifient l'avortement en
homicide aggravé par la circonstance
qu'il a été commis sur un descendant
donc les peines encourues sont beaucoup
plus lourdes est en effet en 2008 puis
en 2007 en appel que dans à masquer sa a
été condamné à 30 ans de prison
donc effectivement elle en a accompli
aux ailes et elle a été libéré en
février 2018
or elle et elle est quand même condamné
voilà pourquoi choisir ce thème pour
pour cette plaidoirie
je trouve ça très intéressant ce qui
m'aide énormément de droits de l'homme
de droits fondamentaux que ce soit le
droit au procès équitable à la santé
l'interdiction des discriminations
et puis de par mon cursus universitaire
je suis très sensible aux droits de
l'homme en amérique latine ça me tenait
à coeur de présenter un sujet une
affaire en lien avec l'amérique latine
et comment vous l'avez préparer cette
plaidoirie sur quels arguments où vous
êtes appuyé alors comme comme je viens
de vous le dire principalement le droit
au procès équitable le fait qu' il ya
une requalification par les juges
alors même que le code pénal salvadorien
prévoit un article dédié à l'avortement
qui prévoit des peines bien sûr
inférieur à l'homicide aggravée
et puis les discriminations également à
l'égard des femmes le droit à l'accès
aux soins
puisqu'il ya tout un contexte un petit
peu de stigmatisation des femmes qui
n'ont pas accès à des soins sans
discrimination finalement donc j'ai
trouvé cette affaire très intéressante
dernière chose il nous reste 30 secondes
comment va se dérouler la finale vous
allez avoir dix minutes devant le public
devant le jury pour présenter cette
plaidoirie
voilà donc je vais avoir dix minutes
pour pouvoir présenter cette affaire et
le but est de faire ressentir au public
ce que j'ai pu ressentir en préparant
cette plaidoirie
l'objectif d'une bonne plaidoiries sont
quelques minutes dire l'essentiel il
faut aller très vite et être qu'on voit
là dire l'essentiel de cette plaidoirie
aller très vite
voilà c'est ça eh bien on vous souhaite
bonne chance ce concours cette finale du
concours de plaidoiries des
élèves-avocats ça se déroule donc ce 26
et janvier ce samedi au mémorial de caen
merci elle aura duré neuf ans était avec
eux et je rappelle que vous êtes élève à
la haute école des avocats de la cour
d'appel de versailles qui est située à
viroflay une page e économie à présent
aujourd'hui et malgré la neige
billancourt organisation premier forum
de l'emploi particularité les recruteurs
étaient des agences d'intérim des offres
proposées dans les secteurs de la
restauration du bâtiment ou encore de la
logistique le reportage d'aurélie ans
depuis plusieurs mois à ce dîner
originaire de lui en cours est à la
recherche d'un emploi après plusieurs
expériences dans la vente il est
néanmoins ouvert à toute proposition que
pourrait lui présenter cette agence
d'intérim cv elle a pris un peu les
informations qu'elle avait besoin de
savoir sur moi et normand voilà j'espère
être au contact et à la fin de la
semaine vraiment comme quand même la
jada six agences d'intérim étaient
présentes
c'est la première fois que la ville de
guyancourt organise ce type de
manifestation objectif permettre aux
demandeurs d'emploi d'avoir un premier
contact et d'échanger avec les
recruteurs les agences d'intérim nous
ont fait part effectivement de de ce
souci de pouvoir recruter quelques fois
sur des postes soit pas hautement
qualifiés ou mais des postes
effectivement de maintenance et donc
mais y'a tout il ya dans la restauration
il ya énormément de profil qui sont
proposées aujourd'hui les candidats
étaient invités à laisser leur cv auprès
des agences une démarche déjà bénéfique
pour certains j'ai une bonne surprise
je me suis inscrite dans toutes les
agences intérim qui correspondait à mon
domaine et le dernier je pensais que
c'était juste une formation un
accompagnement qui suis allé par
curiosité et finalement ils m'ont
proposé un job ils vont envoyer ma
candidature
un de leurs partenaires et je risque
d'être contactés d'ici une semaine
malgré la neige le forum de l'emploi de
guyancourt a attiré près de 150
personnes
deux prochaines éditions pourrait suivre
le 21 décembre la société via pâques à
rambouillet a été placée en liquidation
judiciaire hypothéquant l'avenir d'une
centaine de salariés face à cette
situation la smart cities campus de la
ville accueillait hier lundi un job
dating l'objectif reclasser ses employés
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
dans ce prix un job dating pour les 95
salariés de la société via pâques c'est
l'événement organisé au sein du smart
cities campus le lieu où étaient
installées leurs sites de production
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt suite à la
liquidation judiciaire prononcée en
décembre dernier pour moi c'est la suite
logique car je veux dire on peut être
représentants des personnels mais il
faut assurer le service après vente
comme on dit on peut pas dire c'est noël
s'est finie en voit on passe à autre
chose pour moi c'est un devoir
aujourd'hui heureusement on a fait notre
deuil
il ya pas qu appartient au passé et on
le laisse au passé puis là on démarre
une nouvelle aventure
on a l'occasion de rencontrer
différentes boîtes différents directeurs
des entreprises pour lesquelles on
n'aurait jamais pensé pouvoir postuler
le smart cities campus le comité
d'entreprise de via paquet la députée
aurore bergé ont organisé cet événement
un élan de solidarité pour le tissu
économique rambolitains l'idée c'est de
faire de cet événement qui dit toujours
un événement évidemment douloureux quand
une entreprise faire mais quand en plus
elle a été si importante pour le
territoire à créer des nouvelles
opportunités les nouvelles opportunités
elle existe aussi sur le territoire
c'est un peu le paradoxe c'est qu'on a
un territoire qui est presque en plein
emploi 5% de taux de chômage à peu près
ici mais on a les entreprises qui
cherchent 25 entreprises du sud-yvelines
des grands groupes des pme et des tpe
présent pour trouver de la main d'oeuvre
et rendre possible le reclassement de
ces personnes c'est un profil que l'on
peut trouver notamment chez les ch et
les personnes qui travaillaient chez les
ch et via pack donc j'en ai rencontré
plusieurs qui avait qui avait à peu près
se profile à la fin de la journée 15
contrats ont déjà été signés
d'autres salariés ont un deuxième rendez
vous 2 prévu pour approfondir le premier
entretien la le département compte
beaucoup de groupes d'entrepreneurs en
voici un nouveau livre in business club
a été lancé le 17 janvier dernier au
club de golf de la boulie à versailles
les précisions de nicolas danse
ils sont ici pour faire du business une
cinquantaine de dirigeants d'entreprises
yvelinois ont participé au lancement de
l'ibpt line business club une
association pour créer des relations
entre les sociétés du territoire il ya
beaucoup de d'entreprise yvelinoise
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont travailler avec
ces grandes entreprises du grand paris
et c'est des sous traitants on est là
pour justement les mettre en relation on
voudrait vraiment être un club aussi
ouvert aux femmes femmes dirigeantes
il y en a plein j'en connais plein et on
va aller les chercher on va avons adhéré
au départ ça s'est fait sur une passion
commune qui sont les voitures et les
motos
et
en fait nous on est là pour partager
faire connaître nos produits
faire du business aussi évidemment et
que j'ai aimé que dans la proche de ce
club c'est le côté partage convivialité
ce qui pour nous évidemment c'est de
participer à la croissance et donc de
trouver de nouveaux prospects qui seront
de nouveaux clients plus tard pour
devenir membre d'un club les chefs
d'entreprise sont sélectionnés ils
peuvent participer à des déjeuners
organisés chaque mois avec des
intervenants du monde sportif politique
ou économique
ils reviennent sur leur parcours à
l'image de gérard holtz ce journaliste
sportif parrain du club yvelinois ce
concept une idée du fondateur olivier
albert je pense que dans le sport c'est
un peu comme dans le business si vous
n'êtes pas honnête avec vous même et
avec les autres
si vous n'êtes pas loyal si vous n'êtes
pas au niveau bien vous avez des
déceptions ce qu'on perd et on peut
gagner donc il faut je reçois remettent
en cause systématiquement il faut
s'entraîner il faut travailler et je
pense que l'on retrouve des vraies
valeurs communes entre le sport et
business
l'idée c'est d'échanger ses d'échangés
ce que ce que mon travail à la
télévision mais 44 ans ont pu changer
dans ma vie avec quelle idée j'ai fait
ça et qu'est ce que ça a pu m'apporter
valant gérard holtz interviendra lors du
premier déjeuner le 5 février prochain
au golf de la boulie à versailles
autour de la table avec moi des
chroniqueurs deux journalistes de la
rédaction mélanie poké miquel et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir
mélanie est resté avec nous car on prend
d'abord la direction de villepreux
michael la cérémonie de voeux de la
commune était organisée vendredi dernier
au gymnase l'équipe municipale a
notamment évoqué les nouveaux logements
qui sortiront de terre dans le quartier
du haut des moulins tout à fait grégory
le maire de la commune stéphane à
mirambeau l'a annoncé ce vendredi soir
la ville comptera plus de 400 logements
supplémentaires d'ici le mois de juin
dans ce nouveau quartier de ville proue
avec ces nouvelles constructions
la population devrait passer de dix
mille habitants en 2015 à plus de 13
mille habitants une nécessité à pour le
maire une ville
nous nous n'avons pas le choix quand on
voit qu'on nous n'avons aucune fiscalité
professionnelle
la seule possibilité que nous avons
aujourd'hui pour contrebalancer les
baisses de dotations de l'état c'est de
se développer de faire venir du monde et
donc de donner toutes les conditions
pour que les gens aient envie de venir à
ville propre
c'est ce que nous faisons l'augmentation
de la population ne sera pas le seul
objectif de villepreux en 2019
présentation des grands projets par le
maire de la commune villes pro est une
ville qui bouge beaucoup
on n'a pas beaucoup de moyens mais on a
une force incroyable
on trouve toujours des choses pour
régler les problèmes
donc oui il ya des choses qui bougent
l'école se construit
le parc forestier va aussi se mettre en
action se mettre en branle les choses
avancent à plusieurs niveaux on
reconstruit la cuisine centrale pour
nous permettre de rendre beaucoup plus
efficace la préparation de nos repas la
ville lancera également cette année des
études de faisabilité sur un grand parc
urbain de 19 mille mètres carrés en
entrée de ville pour le mener à bien
tous ses projets le maire de la commune
stéphane mirambeau a annoncé vouloir se
représenter lors des prochaines
élections municipales pour à nouveau
mandat des élections qui seront
programmés à l'année prochaine
merci michael pour toutes ces précisions
sur cette commune de villepreux mélanie
avec vous tout de suite le coup de coeur
culture la commanderie continue son
exploration des arts visuels du corps du
mouvement pour sa nouvelle exposition le
site saint quentinois a donné carte
blanche
un photographe qu'est ce qui vous a plu
mélanie la simplicité des photos alors
simplicité dans le bon sens du terme
elle est apparente allez le voir danois
même c'est le photographe exposé qui a
capturé le mouvement 26 chesnais d'une
carte blanche comme vous l'avez dit
gregory pendant un an
l'artiste nordiste est allé à la
rencontre des corps surtout décor
artistique il a photographié des
danseurs des circassiens le résultat de
son travail des nets des flous une
impression de vie comme si les danseurs
les artistes à l'équité à les clichés
pour danser devant les spectateurs et
les artistes photographier ne sont pas
inconnu des amateurs de culture à saint
quentin
et oui puisque le dal ramène s'est
attaché à des compagnies en résidence ou
en représentation sur le territoire on y
retrouve christian et françois ben aïm
la compagnie masala deux fois de
boussouf ou encore la compagnie la main
l'homme de clément d'azun le travail
s'est fait avec la mission dense de
l'agglomération des précisions et cofely
petit la responsable des arts visuels de
la commanderie l'idée c'était de croiser
aussi les artistes que nous programmons
et puis les rencontres se font ne se
font pas et là ça c'est fait il se
trouve que notre partenariat avec la
mission danse ça a été de faire qu' il
puisse rencontrer des chorégraphes donc
il a rencontré plusieurs chorégraphies
l'a incité à plusieurs spectacles et
pour découvrir tout cela mais benneteau
corpus et a exposé à la commanderie des
templiers jusqu'au 10 mars
merci mélanie on vous retrouve dans un
instant pour votre émission le cetud
culture avec d'autres informations
d'autres expositions également à
découvrir sur le territoire et deux
informations avant de se quitter on
parlait de la neige en début d'émission
quelques belles et insolite images à
vous partager celle du parc du château
de versailles complètement blanc
aujourd'hui le domaine est resté tout de
même ouvert au public ce mardi le pays
entier également sous la neige c'est le
spectacle offert par france miniature
qui a partagé une vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux le site qui lancera sa nouvelle
saison le premier week-end d'avril
et puis il habitait à les yvelines c'est
d'ailleurs dans sa demeure de
villennes-sur-seine que son coeur s'est
arrêté on l'a appris ce matin
l'accordéoniste marcel azzola est décédé
hier à 91 ans le musicien a participé au
renouveau de son instrument en lui
donnant une dimension jazz il aura
marqué les esprits par sa prestation
dans le titre vesoul de jacques brel
le chanteur lui lançant le fameux
chauffe marcel chauffe on se quitte
d'ailleurs sur un extrait merci d'avoir
suivi ce journal est belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]
le voyage est fini meilleur jeune
même l'enfant de la balle
faire l'accordéon
[Applaudissements]
gfr
calais lagarde
[Musique]